bonjour et bienvenue sur france 24 et
sur radio france internationale notre
invité aujourd'hui et cellou dalein
diallo c'est le président de l'union des
forces démocratiques de guinée est avec
moi pour conduire cet entretien laurent
correau de rfi bonjour cellou dalein
diallo bonjour alors cette semaine 58
partis d'opposition dont le vôtre ont
signé une déclaration sur la transition
une déclaration qui affirme que la junte
au pouvoir depuis six mois maintenant
ces cartes de l'état de droit et traîne
volontairement pour revenir à l'ordre
constitutionnel
est-ce que d'après vous le colonel
mamadou doumbouya a décidé de se
maintenir au pouvoir coûte que coûte
je peux pas des saints pour l'instant
c'est qu'on a déploré dans cette
déclaration c'est la marginalisation de
la classe politique acquis en tête des
agendas cachés et
visiblement ne peut pas l'associer à la
définition du contenu de la transition
je parle de la durée de la transition de
l'organisation des élections de la
l'abrogation de la constitution les
grandes lignes tout au moins et
le code électoral le fichier électoral
tous ces éléments qui concourent à
l'organisation des élections permettant
de mettre en place des institutions
légitimes
est ce que le colonel veut se maintenir
au pouvoir
aussi longtemps que possible
on ne peut pas donner une réponse mais
six mois le sentiment quand même oui
après six mois après le coup d'état
jusqu'à présent on n'a pas une durée de
la transition
on a dit que cette transition cette
durée devrait être défini par le cnrd
décide de l'orientation l'agente donc la
junte si vous voulez et les les forces
vives les forces vives bien entendu
c'est aussi les partis politiques mais
jusqu'à présent il ya eu des grandes
messes où on a été invité le colonel où
nous a demandé de faire des propositions
d'un coup quand au contenu de la
transition on les a faites
on a proposé des durées de transe la
transition mais la charte de la
transition n'a pas tenu compte des
propositions de la plupart des
propositions des partis politiques alors
justement la mission conjointe cedeao nu
qui est venu à conakry a constaté le non
respect du délai de six mois qu'elle
avait fixé en septembre dernier elle se
dit également très préoccupé par
l'absence de chronogramme acceptable
qu'est ce que vous attendez de la cedeao
plus de fermeté peut-être écouter nous
avions demandé à la cedeao de ne pas
sanctionner la junte lorsque la pluie le
pouvoir ont estimé que monsieur alpha
conde exercer un mandat un troisième
illégal et illégitime et qu'on a salué
le intervention
maintenant temps d'une souhaitons que la
cedeao accompagnent le processus pour
qu' on puisse revenir à l'ordre
constitutionnel dans un délai
raisonnable vous souhaitez un médiateur
de la cedeao oui absolument parce que la
crise de confiance est tellement
profonde en guinée que parfois pour
qu'on puisse entendre aplanir nos
divergences on a besoin d'une personne
nutt accepté par toutes les parties
alors la durée de la transition c'est
vraiment là où il ya une pierre
d'achoppement au burkina une transition
de trois ans a été décidé est-ce que
d'après vous c'est ce que vise la junte
en guinée c'est brian document qui
circule dans l'authenticité n'est pas un
pour vérifier qu'il propose quatre mois
pendant quatre ans je ne sais pas si
c'est un projet de la junte mais en tout
cas ça nous paraît trop nous au niveau
de risque acceptable pour vous pour nous
on avait proposé 15 mois alors que la
cbn avait proposé 6 mais lorsqu'on a
essayé d'établir un chronogramme sur la
base des actions à mener en affectant un
délai à chaque action compte tenu de
notre expérience on pensait que 15 mois
était largement suffisant pour organiser
des élections et mettre en place les
institutions légitimes est ce que vous
diriez cellou dalein diallo qu'en l'état
actuel des choses le divorce est
consommé entre la junte et les
politiques n'a pour le moment on a lancé
un appel à la junte pour qu'on puisse
s'asseoir comme met en place un cadre
permanent de dialogue qui réunira le
cnrd le gouvernent le cnt les partis
politiques la société civile avec la
participation des partenaires techniques
et financiers dans la plaisance pourrait
aider à aplanir certaines divisions
compte tenu de la crise de confiance qui
est née entre notamment la classe
politique et la junte donc une solution
nous sommes toujours possible oui une
solution est toujours possible je pense
que l'absence de dialogue est source de
conflits il faut éviter les conflits il
faut se rappeler que les événements
tragiques du 28 septembre 2009 était la
conséquence d'une rupture du dialogue
avec les égos qui avait naturellement
conduit les uns et les autres à se
radicaliser alors qu'on n'a pas besoin
de ça on a besoin de se retrouver autour
d'une table de décider qu'est ce qu'on
fait de la transition quel est le délai
convenable qu'elle est l'organe de
gestion des élections pour que tout le
monde ait confiance à ce qui sera mis en
place pour éviter les conflits avant ou
après les élections alors justement le
gouvernement a annoncé la tenue
d'assises nationales le 22 mars prochain
ce que c'est un pas vers la solution se
tape c'est pas mon sentiment pour moi il
faut un cadre du colloque où on peut
discuter de délégation des institutions
que j'ai cités se retrouve sur la base
des expériences qu'on a eu des talents
politiques en guinée ailleurs on essaie
de trouver des solutions consensuelles
équipe orienté aussi bien le cnt que le
gouvernement et le cndd est dans
l'action publique pour que l'on puisse
très rapidement aller alors de retour à
l'ordre constitutionnel
cellou dalein diallo vous êtes le
principal leader de l'opposition on
imagine que vous avez tenté de dialoguer
avec le colonel doumbouya on a vu qu au
mali au burkina il ya quand même ne
serait ce un véritable dialogue au moins
des canaux qui existe entre l'opposition
et la junte est ce que vous avez parlé
au colonel doumbouya ce que vous l'avez
vu personnellement j'ai pas pu le
rencontrer pas faute d'avoir essayé mais
ça paye de cette favorable il a refusé
de vous voir enfin je peux considérer ça
comme tel puisque j'ai pas eu de cette
favorable j'ai souhaité le rencontrer
pour donner la vie par rapport à ceux
passés bon je voulais être un partenaire
du cnrd dans cette transition pas moi
seul mais je pense qu'il ya un certain
nombre d'acteurs politiques qui sont
représentatifs dans une certaine mesure
de la population compte tenu des scores
qu'ils ont réalisés compte tenu des
sièges qu'ils ont obtenir l'assemblée ou
dans les élections communales on peut
sur cette base là invité certains et
discuter avec eux pour qu'ils puissent
donner leur avis par rapport à à 7
compte tenu de cette pause sur vous ça
illustre sa volonté d'exclure les
particules a déjà je considère que si on
prend les pays dans lesquels se
déroulent actuellement en détention au
mali le gouvernement et même de la telma
et les partis politiques sont membres du
gouvernement de temps sur le premier
ministre même est ici de la classe
politique au tchad également ce paquet
est ici de l'opposition même si vous par
le passé il a servi le président deby en
appelle même au chef de la rébellion à
déposer les années à venir autour de la
table de dialogue je ne comprends pas
pourquoi en guinée pour refuse de mettre
en place un cadre permanent de dialogue
pour discuter de l'avenir de cette peine
si le dialogue est impossible cellou
dalein diallo l'opposition dit se
réserver le droit d'utiliser tous les
moyens légaux y compris les
manifestations mais est-ce qu'on ne
risque pas de revenir dans un cycle de
violences écoutez on a en guinée les
manifestations
bien sûr ont toujours été réprimés dans
le sang si bien que tout le monde pense
que les manifestations sont violentes
nous nous voulons connaît l'habitude
d'organiser des manifestations bien
encadré qui ne sommes pas violente juste
pour exprimer un désaccord pour exprimer
un ras-le-bol par rapport à certains
pratiquent à certains comportements qui
sont contraires aux règles et principes
de la démocratie de l'état de droit je
pense que c'est un droit reconnu
aujourd'hui citoyenne et aux
associations de marché dans les rues et
sur les places publiques pour donner
pour protester mais pacifiquement sans
violence et on arrive à le faire aussi
même en guinée sous alpha condé le ce
qu'ils ont accepté que cette
manifestation ait lieu on a un cadre est
ensemble on a fait des réunions avec les
forces de défense et de sécurité on a
fait plusieurs manifestations pacifiques
sans qu'il y ait la moindre violence
alors vous avez été cité dans la sphère
dit air guinée il avait aussi été obligé
de quitter votre résidence à conakry
sans vouloir entrer dans les détails de
ces affaires est-ce que vous avez
l'impression
que ce n'est pas une question de justice
mais de vendetta politique absolument
dans la mesure où aucune procédure
habituelle n'a été si oui on a su qu'il
était deuxième en même temps on est allé
exhumé un de ces duels guinée fier de
plus de 20 ans qui s'est inscrit dans le
cadre de dallas d'une série de
privatisations
effectuée sous la pression du fonds
monétaire et de la banque mondiale
c'était juste des relativement d'une
privatisation de la guinée qui avait
commencé dix ans avant avec la vente des
deux boeing 707 et 737 a dit clivé et on
a décidé de liquider l'entreprise à
défaut de trouver un partenaire privé
capable de reprendre la compagnie sas
est sorti ya vingt ans que cela c'est en
2002 que cet avion a été cédée l'avion
présidentiel et la vienne de la guinée
c'est le même à un opérateur privé
guinée ensuite on m'a fait comprendre
que je devais quitter mon domicile que
j'ai acquis en toute légalité dans le
respect de toutes les règles à l'époque
en vigueur puisque il ya eu non
seulement un décret du président a
répondu qu'il a autorisée il ya une
évaluation indépendante du terrain et un
bâtiment de 2 chambres un salon et puis
j'ai contracté un prêt à la banque qui a
financé et a pris une hypothèque sur le
sucre la du terrain et jusqu'à ce que
j'aie fini de régler juste mais alors en
effet donc le but c'est quoi c'est de
vous écarter d'une éventuelle future
élection à l'abord ma réputation sans
doute et peut-être trouvé à moins de les
disqualifier je ne sais pas je suis au
stade de l'interrogation pourquoi ces
deux dossiers en même temps qu'ils
visaient ma personne même si sidya touré
était aussi visé par
la sphère de bâtiments qu'il a acquis
dans les mêmes conditions en toute
régularité qu'avant également oui un mot
également sur alpha condé l'ancien
président qui est toujours actuellement
en exil aux émirats arabes unis est ce
que vous demandez son retour et est ce
que vous demandez éventuellement qu'il
soit jugé je demande je constate que la
demande de la cedeao le cnrd avait
marqué donc son accord pour al fayçal et
et dans les émirats arabes unis et
c'était à moi je pense moi été prolongée
et bien sûr naturellement si la justice
dans le respect de la présomption
d'innocence bien entendu parce qu'on a
exigé aussi dans note le sens qu'on
respecte la prise de ce violent
d'innocence quelle que soit la personne
visée baldé les options de détournement
publics et de corruption s'il ya des
fautes qui sont imputables alpha il faut
que la justice 106 comme pour tous les
autres citoyens
merci cellou dalein diallo et merci à
vous de nous avoir suivi sur nos deux
antennes rfi et france 24
[Musique]